- Hi everyone, welcome
to the Daily Homeroom.
For those of you who aren't
familiar with what this is
or might just be showing up
off of Facebook or YouTube,
this is Khan Academy's way
of making sure that we all
stay connected during school closures.
Obviously Khan Academy,
we're a not for profit,
mission free, world class
education for anyone anywhere.
We could've never predicted
the situation that we're all
in now but over the last many years,
we've been building resources
in math, in science,
in the humanities, in
English and language arts
and for early learners, that
have been free and are free
that are not commercial.
They're supported by
philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
And we've always intended
them to be used in conjunction
with physical classrooms
so students can learn
at their own time and
pace and master concepts.
And also used by students
when they're outside
of the classroom.
Be that tutor that their
family could otherwise
not afford or if they don't have access
to certain types of classes.
And it's translated into
the languages of the world
so we could also imagine
there's parts of the planet
that don't have access to schooling
or the types of schooling
that we would want
for our own children.
And that's where Khan
Academy, we've also seen
playing a role.
But when the school
closures started happening,
we realized it's our duty
to step up and to do more.
And so we wanna provide
more supports for all of you
students, teachers and parents.
We've been running webinars
for parents and teachers
to try to understand, how do
you navigate school closures?
How do you do this somewhat
ad hoc homeschooling
all of a sudden?
On top of that we've been
doing this daily livestream
which is really just a place to talk
about anything, stay connected.
It could be of topics
of interest and topics
that you're struggling with.
I encourage everyone whether
you're watching on Facebook
or on YouTube, we're always
learning about new ways
people are watching this,
put questions on the message
board, have team members
who are going to be surfacing them to us.
And we're also going to have,
I'm going to introduce them
in a second, some experts
on child psychology.
Especially for students
with special learning needs.
So definitely put those questions as well.
But we'll answer all and any questions.
I do wanna make a special
shout out to all of you
who've helped support Khan Academy.
Not only over the years
but especially over
the last few weeks.
We are a nonprofit that runs
through philanthropic donation.
We were running at a deficit
even before this crisis had hit
and as you can imagine
over the last few weeks,
our server utilization is 2x,
3x of what it typically is.
So we need that support
even more now than ever.
A special thanks to Bank
of America, AT&T, Novartis
and Google.org for being some
of the first corporations
to step up but we need more.
We're still running at a deficit.
So definitely get those
questions, questions literally
about anything, I like some
of the fun and frivolous ones
as well and they can also be
serious ones about education
or about the coronavirus or whatever.
But with that, I'd like to introduce
our two guests for today.
We have Laura Phillips who's
a clinical psychologist,
a neuro psychologist I should say,
at the Child Mind Institute.
And we also have Dave
Anderson who I believe
is going to be joining us as well.
Laura, maybe a good place to start is,
what are you seeing out there
now that a lot of you know,
we have this forced social
distancing, what do you see
as the major issues that
parents are coping with,
that students are coping with?
- Sure, so parents have
had to turn their homes
into their kid's classrooms.
And my patient population tends to be kids
who are struggling with
learning disorders or ADHD.
And this is challenging
for all students now
to have to pivot and shift their learning
to their home environment
but it's particularly challenging for kids
with learning disabilities
who really do need
explicit, teacher directed,
recursive learning approaches
but just aren't feasible right
now through remote learning.
So parents are really
having to step up in a way
that they've never needed
to before and provide
the support that teachers
were traditionally
providing their students
without any training.
And it's a really big ask.
I say to all the parents with whom I work,
it doesn't matter how bright
you are, what a rock star
you are at your job, how
well you know your students
and your student's learning
profile, how well you parent
your individual student,
teaching them is a very different thing.
And a lot of what teachers
actually end up doing
in the classroom is
really behavior management
and modifying the way that
they present information
in a way that makes it
engaging and appealing
to their students.
And parents now have to
be the ones doing that
without the training and the experience
that their teachers do.
So a lot of the questions
I'm getting really is about,
"How do I keep my student engaged?
How do I manage my student's frustration?
And how do I manage newly
occurring or historic,
long-standing oppositional
behaviors in the context
of frustrating academic situations?"
- And so what are these techniques?
What are some you know, I've
experienced some of that
in my own household.
I think it's for all students,
not just special needs
students but some of this
might be more pronounced
with those students.
What are some tangible
things you would tell parents
who maybe are having trouble
keeping their kids motivated
or engaged right now?
- Well, the first is to
cut yourself some slack
and to cut your kids some slack
because this is really hard.
No one has ever needed to
do this with the exception
of parents who opted to
homeschool their kids
before this occurred.
But this is a completely
unprecedented and challenging
and stressful situation
for kids and for parents
who are having to balance
the responsibilities
of working from home
and raising their kids
and now schooling them.
So the first thing is really
cut yourself some slack.
This is not the time to
strive for perfection.
And the most important
thing really is to maintain
physical and mental health right now.
And after that,
communication with teachers
is really critical.
A lot of the students with
whom I work have a lot
of either environmental modifications
or school work modifications
that the teachers
can really help the parents
understand what level
of independence they should be expecting
with their students, how
much time should they expect
their students to be able
to work independently
on a task without a teacher,
a parent stepping in
and either prompting
or checking in on them.
Or some students might even need a parent
sitting next to them the entire time
to keep themselves on task.
But the teacher's gonna be
the best person to inform
what the child's capabilities are.
That's gonna vary depending
on the child's age,
depending on their
child's learning profile.
So again, I would really
turn to the teachers
and partner with the teachers
so that you really understand
what your role should be in
supporting your students.
And to the extent that you
can, maintain structure
and consistency you know, which
might mean starting the day
at the same time.
Kids should be I think,
waking up at the same
that they historically
wake up, having good meals
at standard times, going
to bed at the same time,
setting your kids up
for success with respect
to getting sufficient sleep, eating well.
If your children are
prescribed medication,
making sure that they continue to take
their medication as prescribed.
Making sure that they have
the tools that they need
to complete the online work.
So whether that is computer or laptop,
knowing how to use the
various online platforms
that schools are rolling
out and schedules.
Schedules I think, are really,
really critical for students
with anxiety, for students
with ADHD, who have a hard time
not knowing what's gonna come next.
And yeah, you look like you're
about to pop in with something.
- And how do you know,
you know as you mentioned,
and I completely understand.
You mentioned parents
might have to sit down
next to their student or
they need to understand
from their teacher but what
we're seeing, in fact I think
this is the majority
situation is parents are also
having to work right now.
And then they're not
getting a lot of information
in some cases, you know 'cause
teachers are still trying
to figure out, some districts
are still figuring out
the virtualization plans.
And in many cases, the
special needs students,
they haven't even gotten that
far to think about that yet.
So what do you tell those
parents who, they're trying
to work simultaneously but
you know, their student
might need someone to sit down,
how do they navigate that?
- So shifts I think are really important.
Partnering with your partner
and trying to tag team
so that one person can feel
like they're getting work done
while supporting their students.
I think that part of co
parenting is really critical
and I understand that that's not feasible
for a lot of people but
that's one thing that I think
can help parents feel as
though they're still keeping up
with their work.
Although, the reality is no
one's gonna be productive
as they would be under ideal circumstances
and these aren't ideal circumstances.
But again, I would encourage
parents to really talk
to teachers and to turn
to resources like you.
You provide really nice I think,
complimentary educational
programming that can supplement
a lot of what schools are rolling.
I'm finding that schools
really vary in the amount
of direction and structure
that they're providing
in their rollout of curriculum.
Some schools have a very strict schedule
and they have online class
discussions throughout the day,
other schools have just sent
home packets of information
which can be really overwhelming
for students to sit down.
So when that's occurring,
I encourage parents really
to do a lot of chunking for
them trying to break down
these larger packets into
smaller, more manageable chunks
so that their kids don't feel overwhelmed
and then avoid the tasks.
And alternating it with
more appealing activities
so that they feel like they
have some sort of reward
at the end of engaging in
something that's really stressful
and frustrating for them.
- I'm getting some
questions over Facebook,
one from Elizabeth Handlon.
It says, "Any advice on
probing your children
who aren't innately
talkers but clearly dealing
with difficulty processing?"
- Processing, I'm not sure that
I understand that question.
- Like processing what's going
on in the world right now
or you know, all the sudden
their school's been closed.
How do they cope with it?
They're not talking to
their friends as much,
you know, their parents are
stressed, they're watching
the news, things are going on.
- Yeah, so kids do well
when they have information.
Being in the dark is stressful
and anxiety inducing for anybody.
So I do encourage parents
to give kids information
that they're seeking in a
developmentally appropriate way.
I think that one way to
manage that is to really try
to have kids lead the
conversation by asking questions.
That way, you can answer their questions,
hopefully satisfactorily
without providing perhaps
more information than they're seeking
which could inadvertently
make them more overwhelmed
or anxious by the situation.
But I think it's important to shed light
on a situation for kids.
And also help them understand
that things that you're doing
are intended to make them feel safe.
This is a problem that
adults are working on
but there are concrete
things that kids can do
like staying out of school right now,
washing their hands frequently
and following those rules
as a way to really help
keep themselves safe
which makes them feel as
though they have some control
over the situation.
- And Dave, what's your
sense of these things?
I know we talked about
it a couple days ago,
how do you think about coping
with some of these things?
And I have this other question
from someone who's talking
about having trouble
concentrating in studies
because of social anxiety.
How does that play out in
this type of a situation?
Dave, what do you think about that?
- Right I mean, I think
that you know, if we talk
about anxiety for one sec.
And that's just,
anxiety's often brought on
by new situations.
New things that are unexpected,
things that you haven't
encountered before.
So kids who have been socially anxious
and even have resolved it to some degree
may find themselves newly anxious
in a midst of a kind of new landscape
where they're wondering
when they should jump in
an online classes or
they're wondering how public
their comment might be
or whether or not others
are chatting about them in the background.
There could be a host of new
fears associated with that.
And in reality, the way
we help kids with that
is we help them to think
about the fact that whatever
they might be afraid of you
know, we try to restructure
the moment that even what
they're afraid of the most
might not be that terrible.
And in reality, the things they care about
may still be happening.
And then we also try to
engage in exposure with them
where we say, "Look, it may
mean that you're worried
about how a comment might be perceived
but I need you to make two per class.
And then let's go back
to the evidence and see
how tough that was or how
anxious that made you."
And over time, we can get somebody
from perhaps being anxious
to even participate
up to what their level of
participation might have been
before online education or COVID.
- Yeah, and more questions here.
There's, one student is
talking about how do they deal,
they're having depression at the same time
they have a SAT and a
lot of studies to do.
What advice would you
give for them, either?
- I think Laura and I can
both hit on different parts
of this question.
But I think it's something
where when we see kids
who are preparing for the
SATs, what we're thinking about
and I'll go back to a point
that Laura made earlier
which is just about chunking.
We know that somebody
whose mood might be low
need to not think about
the entirety of preparation
for the SAT but rather you
know, think about it just
what they're gonna get done today.
And then how they're
gonna reward themselves
with something that's what we
call behaviorally activating
which means that we know that
it's gonna improve their mood
to some degree.
So we try to plan out with
teenagers, do the work first,
put in manageable chunk
and likely a smaller chunk
than pre COVID then figure out
how you're gonna do something
for your mood and something
to fell connected you know,
afterwards just to keep everything
kind of in that variety.
- Yeah, I would just
add I mean, I don't know
if this is preexisting
depression but certainly
social isolation and the lack
of accessibility of things
that make us feel good, lowers our mood.
So another thing that I try
to encourage parents to do
is to the extent that they
can, really try to mimic
their normal life but
with sticking to somewhat
of a typical routine.
And finding ways, even
if you can't go outside
and have play dates with
friends face to face,
trying to schedule virtual
play dates, making sure
that you're scheduling
time for outdoor activity
if you're in a location where
you're allowed to go outside.
But certainly physical activity we know,
has mood boosting effects and
learning boosting effects.
So I think certainly scheduling in time
for physical exercise and
outdoor time is really critical
both to support learning
and to support mood.
And again, really trying
to keep the days as close
to a typical day as you can.
I heard recently about a
father who has a student
who's on the autism
spectrum and takes his son
for a drive every morning as though
he were driving him to school.
It's just a way to maintain
some semblance of normalcy
for him and it really helps
him get into the mindset
of being in school.
So that may not apply to
the case of this student
with depression but really
trying to mimic things
that a typical day, is
helpful for students.
- I will say one other thing--
- And what advice would
you say, oh go head.
- Oh, I was just gonna say,
I will say one other point.
For kids who are struggling
with social anxiety
or depression, some of the
things that Dr. Phillips
and I are talking about are
not necessarily intuitive.
And the great thing about
at least how organizations
are adapting to the
COVID crisis now is that
organizations like ours,
the Child Mind Institute
and others have really moved
to a telehealth kind of forum
where not only are we
working with active patients
but we'll also do brief
consultations on issues like this
just to ensure that families
have support during this time.
Because you know, it's
not intuitive how to deal
with this crisis in the context of kids
who are battling mental health disorders.
- And we have a question
here from YouTube,
Priscilla Cruze is asking,
"My child does have ADHD.
How much time is enough to
homeschool for a second grader
without pushing them too far?
They're normally in school for six hours."
And I think this is a
question that all parents
are struggling with, is normally
school is six, seven hours
but what is the minimum and
what's maybe the maximum
for this type of a scenario?
- It's a great question.
And again, I would encourage,
I think that the teachers
can be helpful in at least advising what--
I mean, if the teachers
have concrete tasks
for students to complete,
it would be the goal
for students to get through that work.
And you might wanna consult
with teachers about how long
they would expect students
to either be engaged
in that work on a daily basis
or how long they would expect
that packet to take for
the student to complete.
And beyond that the thing is,
especially with very young
students and I'm considering
even a second grade student
a very young student,
so many things are educational
even if they're not
traditionally found in a classroom.
So the silver lining, I mean
I think they're are a lot
of silver linings of this
crisis but there are other
learning opportunities that
students might not otherwise
have exposure to.
So we have students who
are now doing more chores
around the house and they're learning
how to help their parents
cook, and that's a lesson.
There's math involved in that,
there's chemistry involved
in that, there's a lot of
executive functioning developing
with organization and sequencing of steps
and patience and perseverance
and frustration tolerance.
So there's learning that's
taking place even if it's not
traditional classroom type learning.
Boredom is actually I think,
a very critical experience
for students to have that in our culture
we don't have many opportunities to feel.
And we know that boredom
really is how kids develop
and nurture their creativity.
So I think you're gonna see
a lot of skills coming out
of this crisis that might
not have otherwise had
the opportunity to emerge.
And I think that that's something
that I really want parents
to try to focus on to
the extent that they can.
So even if they're not
engaged in traditionally
academic tasks, there are other ways
for them to be learning right now.
- All right, and that's useful.
The last question for
today on this topic is
from YouTube Ketrin Setumeong
is asking, "How can I manage
being a perfectionist when I'm studying?
It makes me stressed because
I always say to myself,
'I must get the best and do the best?'"
How do you cope with that?
And this is something
adults and children I think,
struggle with or many do.
- I'll start it this way,
I think one of the things
that we talk about
perfectionism and young people
or students of any age
right now is that you know,
the landscape has truly changed.
Many colleges and high
schools are trying to adapt
their grading systems right
now to what's going on
in online education and
may not be able to grade
in exactly the same way.
And of course, for people
who already were concerned
about grades or wanted
their work to be perfect,
that also means that the landscape
for their assessment's changing.
That can lead to a lot of anxiety.
You know, one of the things that I think
we're speaking about a lot
with families and educators
right now is that as we
all adapt to this crisis
it's good to kind of
capitalize on what we think
is going well or what
quality work we think others
are producing and not to expect
perfect or the same level
of work that we would've
seen prior to this
because people are just dealing
with so many more challenges.
So again, you know, I think we'll go back
to an earlier point which is communicating
with your teachers about
what's expected on assignments
is a good thing.
But many folks who are
proud of perfectionism,
we're also trying to
include the coping thought
that people are more empathic right now,
they're more compassionate,
they're more willing
to possibly grade you
positively because they know
that maybe you're dealing with
more than you would usually.
So it's not something
where every assignment
has to be perfect, you may actually have
a little bit more space, going
back to Dr. Phillips's point
about silver linings for creativity.
- That's super useful.
You know, we've gotten questions
even before this crisis
about things like
procrastination and you know,
and one of the causes of
procrastination is the fear
that maybe you aren't
able to do it as much
as you thought or it might be harder.
But with kind of, whether
you call it perfectionism
or procrastination, it's really
you know, just get started.
And then that motion might help
unblock some of the things.
Well Laura, Dave, thanks
so much for joining today.
This was super useful.
I think a lot of people got
some really interesting insights
into this, thank you.
- Thanks for having us.
- Great, stay well.
- So thanks everyone for joining today.
You know, I'll just give a
reminder that this is a place
for y'all to stay connected in this time
of social distancing.
You know, send us requests,
send us questions,
send us even folks that you
might wanna see on this forum
and we'll try to reach out to them.
I think a lot of people are
out there in the world today
trying to understand how they can help,
how they can help you as
parents, students and teachers.
I will remind everyone
again, we are not for profit.
If you're in a position,
please think about donating
to Khan Academy.
It's support like that that allows us
to support many other folks.
One of the things that
you could expect to see
over the next couple of days,
and actually we've already
released it a little bit, you're
gonna see a little bit more
of the next day or two is
we released those schedules
for students of different
age groups three weeks ago.
And we got a lot of
positive feedback from y'all
that it was useful to structure
the day along the lines
that we were just hearing
from, from our guest experts.
What we've launching
right now, today, tomorrow
are actually learning plans.
Now that it's becoming clear
that school is going to be
out of session probably through
the end of the school year,
students are trying to figure
out and parents and teachers,
what could be done not
just over those two months
but potentially through the
summer so you don't have
five months of not just only
not learning but learning loss.
And so expect to see some
links for learning plans
on how you can space yourself
out, especially in math.
If you're a sixth
grader, a seventh grader,
an algebra student, a
third grader, to make sure
that you are operating
at grade level and beyond
as we go into the new school year.
And tomorrow and the
next few lives streams
we'll go into a lot more depth on that.
We just published a YouTube
video for those of y'all
that are on YouTube.
It's actually the latest
video that we just made public
on our YouTube channel
where if you look at,
it explains what these
learning plans look like
and it has links in the description
to the various learning plans.
And we're going to be posting it
on other social media shortly.
So with that, thank you
so much for joining us.
This is just a way for all
of us to stay connected
and stay healthy and stay safe.